today's video has been made possible
thanks to yours app more about that in a
bit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when u.s president barack obama
announced his intention to reach an
agreement with the ayatollah regime on
iran's nuclear program back in 2014
relations between rija and washington
began to crack the former alliance the
old partnership the special relationship
between these two countries that began
back in 1945 when u.s president franklin
roosevelt met with the saudi king at the
suez canal was starting to crumble for
rydia washington's pact with tehran was
little short of a betrayal and since
then things have gone from bad to worse
now the russian invasion of ukraine and
rydia's systematic refusal to support
the u.s position and requests has made
things worse than ever now the russian
invasion of ukraine and rydia's
systematic refusal to support the us's
position and requests has made things
worse than ever but why on earth does
saudi arabia continue to support russia
and do so even though it may jeopardize
its special relationship with the united
states why have relations between radio
and washington deteriorated so much what
is left of the old friendship between
these two countries well joe biden be
able to put the relationship back on
track in this video we will answer all
of these questions but before knowing
about this special relationship begins
let me talk to you about yours app your
zap allows you to achieve a better
version of yourself with a few daily
life hacks through specially developed
meditation rituals sleep stories yoga
practices soundscapes and more your's
app will provide an irresistible safe
haven where you can take guilt-free time
for yourself did you know that in the us
alone over nine million workers are
regularly working night shifts whether
you have a shift work sleep disorder or
you just have trouble sleeping with your
zap you will find among many other
things hours of ultra relaxing sleep
stories to help you beat insomnia and to
fall into a quicker deeper sleep state
every single night they'll have you
dreaming in no time providing a better
quality of slumber so you will feel
refreshed every time you wake or maybe
you just need a little help controlling
your emotional state select from a
library of ambient soundscapes to suit
your mood from relaxing lo-fi and dreamy
nature sounds to help you switch off to
supercharged tunes and tantalising asmr
to awaken the mind the body and the
senses and what's really great is that
it's all tailored to you there's no need
to wade through videos and audio that
aren't for you because who's got time
for that using clever technology they'll
find the best program based on your
habits and needs to help both your body
and mind i personally like using the
mood check-in feature that tailors the
content specifically for how i'm feeling
at the moment they have a special offer
for everyone here on visualpolitik you
can now go to yourzapp.com forward slash
politik or use the code politik and save
sixty percent of the annual plan and now
let's continue with today's video
[Music]
special relationship
[Music]
in 1945 president roosevelt and saudi
king ibn saud sealed the oil for defence
pact a pact whereby the united states
obtained oil at reasonable prices while
guaranteeing the security of the saudi
kingdom in return it was the beginning
of a long friendship that would leave a
profound mark on world history although
that was not really the first major
contact between the two countries twelve
years earlier in 1933 the saudi
government had partnered with
rockefeller's own standard oil company
and so little by little close ties were
forged between the two countries for
example the united states established a
delegation in jeddah in 1942 upgrading
it to an embassy in 1949
for his part king evan saud urged the
united states to open a consulate in
duran in 1944 to serve u.s citizens
employed by the arabian american oil
company now known as aramco in 1943 he
invited the united states to build an
airfield in duran which in the u.s air
force maintained until 1962. the
understanding was such that in 1944 the
united states extended the lend lease
program to saudi arabia so that saudi
arabia could buy a lot of equipment from
the giant u.s arms supermarket and
shortly thereafter in 1951 the two
states signed a mutual defense
assistance agreement which for example
established the first u.s military
training mission in the saudi kingdom
but hold on a minute because rydia has
always maintained an independent foreign
policy and unlike other countries in the
gulf cooperation council has always had
many reservations about the presence of
u.s troops on its territory
for example the saudi government had a
hard time making the decision to accept
the deployment of half a million u.s
troops during the first gulf war and
more recently during the post-9 11
invasion of afghanistan the saudis did
not allow the americans to use their
territory for military operations while
they were subsequently very critical of
the invasion of iraq not to mention the
two oil embargoes led by saudi arabia in
1967 after the six day war and in 1973
after the arab israeli war the second
oil embargo in particular wreaked havoc
in the united states
so as you can see we're not exactly
talking about a relationship of
unconditional love not at all the
special relationship between rydia and
washington has been a key part of u.s
foreign policy over recent decades but
the relationship has always been marked
by misunderstandings misgivings and
mistrust in fact other persian gulf
countries have much closer relations
with the united states
[Music]
for example bahrain is home to the fifth
largest u.s fleet kuwait hosts thousands
of u.s soldiers at eight bases and in
qatar the united states has hosted the
al-udid base since 1996 one of the most
significant u.s air bases in the world
things improved however with trump in
the white house the former president bet
on saudi arabia to the detriment of
qatar when setting his priorities in the
middle east even though this meant the
departure of his secretary of state rex
tillerson and despite the fact that
qatar is a very close ally of washington
but while there seemed to be a certain
romance during that era the arrival of
joe biden to power has meant quite the
opposite
the saudis see the current
administration as the heir to the obama
administration that backed the arab
spring wanted to reduce the u.s presence
in the middle east and sealed the
nuclear deal with iran all of which
infuriated the saudi government led at
the time by the late king abdullah to
top it all off biden unlike trump has
been tremendously critical of the saudi
regime in the aftermath of the macabre
heinous and vile murder of the
journalist jamal khashoggi the current
u.s president went so far as to call
saudi arabia a pariah country
but take note visualpolitik fans because
all these misgivings and disagreements
are not only a matter for the saudi
government muhammad bin salman is
driving a major transformation in the
country we've talked about this a lot in
a lot of videos however he is not
particularly well regarded by the
americans extrajudicial murder will kind
of do that let's just say that in
washington they consider the new saudi
leader to be too impulsive and to hardly
be trusted look at it this way
in washington they understand that the
character has almost completely
destroyed the balance of power and saudi
royalty that he's reforming the saudi
political system so that everything
revolves around him that is recklessly
dedicated to get involved in the war in
yemen despite warnings that it would be
a huge mistake that he ordered the vile
murder of khashoggi and to top it all
off he has attempted to blackmail the
united states with his oil policy on
several occasions
[Music]
and all this without mentioning the
silent coup he perpetrated in 2017 when
he overthrew and imprisoned crown prince
mohammed bin nayef who had had very good
relations with the united states thanks
to his fight against the presence of
al-qaeda in the country so much for
washington now what could explain so
many misunderstandings weren't the two
countries supposed to have a special
relationship and even mutual dependence
in such important fields as energy
security and defense well my
visualpolitik fans the truth is that
during the last two decades a copernican
turn has taken place
[Applause]
the united states no longer needs saudi
oil and that has been a turning point
today exports to the united states
represent less than five percent of
saudi crude oil exports an export that
is now mainly destined to the far east
especially to countries such as china
japan south korea and taiwan exports to
china alone represent more than twice as
much as exports to the united states
and believe me when i tell you that this
has changed everything the shale oil
revolution in the united states made
washington stop giving so much
importance to the middle east and that's
where things stood when to top it all
off the russian invasion of ukraine
arrived check this out
[Music]
it's all about the money
[Music]
this could end up being a huge turning
point time and again rydia has refused
to condemn moscow for its vicious
invasion of ukraine and has even
expressed support for its partners in
the group known as opec plus while the
white house was leading a campaign to
isolate russia saudi arabia's leaders
continued to state things like this
saudi arabia signal support for russia's
role in opec plus as sanction pressure
mounts and something that is even worse
for us interests saudi arabia has
steadfastly refused to pump much more
oil in an attempt to mitigate the effect
of sanctions against russia sanctions
that have driven oil and gas prices to
their highest levels in more than a
decade of course everything has an
explanation
[Music]
you see saudi arabia remains the world's
largest exporter of crude oil and with
brent crude at over 100 a barrel money
is pouring back into the saudi coffers
here on visualpolitik we have already
told you how this country faces a
complicated future on the one hand its
population is very young and accustomed
to a relatively high standard of living
on the other hand however their oil
revenues are no longer enough to support
an ever-growing population in an economy
that fundamentally continues to depend
on black gold in saudi arabia you
basically either work for the government
or for the oil industry
the government of mohammed bin salman
wants to change this situation and is
doing so with plans such as vision 2030.
the problem is that in order to carry
out these plans the country needs money
a lot of money and financially the last
few years have been very very bad for
the kingdom between 2015 and 2020 the
fall in oil prices caused the country to
consume a substantial chunk of its cash
reserves we are talking about hundreds
of billions a hole that seemed to be
leading them straight into the financial
abyss but now that's changed the new oil
prices mean that saudi arabia now has
the chance to rebuild its reserves and
return to financing investments in
foreign companies and major projects
that reduce dependence on crude oil
the windfall gains from the additional
revenues we will get from higher oil
prices will essentially be invested in
resilience whether it's replenishing
reserves paying down debt or investing
in one-off transformational products
through our wealth fund that really
helps us accelerate diversification
plans faisal ibrahim minister of economy
and planning saudi arabia even the saudi
government is considering selling more
abramco shares now the aramco has soared
on the stock market and has once again
become the world's most valuable company
after overtaking apple
but to achieve all these plans the
country needs the oil price to continue
to rise for a good period of time during
2022 alone the country is expected to
earn more than 280 billion us dollars
from oil sales 118 billion more than in
previous years and that my friends this
goes without saying is a lot and i mean
a lot of money support for russia may
tighten enough to ensure that these
revenues keep coming in and richa may
also be thinking that while russian
production begins to be reduced by
sanctions they can release a lot more
oil without substantially depressing
prices this could give the kingdom a
margin of three or four years of
extraordinary income we could be talking
about more than 500 or 600 billion
dollars a fortune with which its
economic diversification plans would be
accelerated of course you kind of need
to be wary of miraculous plans check
this out
[Music]
don't count your chickens before they've
hatched
[Music]
the united states may no longer be such
an important client and rydia may now
have its other priorities but its
relationship with the american giant
remains indispensable to the house of
saud as much as it pains mohammed bin
salman the united states remains
terribly important to saudi arabia the
united states is the home of big finance
big business and big multinationals from
around the world saudi arabia alone a
country desperately seeking to diversify
its economy away from oil has more than
800 billion invested in the united
states compared to less than 100 billion
in china and yes at this point some of
you might think that this is a point of
weakness for the united states that
saudi arabia could just take its money
and run off with it elsewhere however
this is not so easy saudi arabia wants
to diversify its oil economy and for
this it needs the large u.s
multinationals nor is it easy for the
petrol monarchy to find another
destination where it can deposit such
large amounts of money with total
security and liquidity
and it is not only an economic issue
from the military point of view the
dependence is even greater the saudi
armed forces are almost entirely
dependent on the u.s military industry
to give you an idea between 2015 and
2019 73 of saudi military purchases were
made from u.s companies between 2008 and
2020 alone the saudis spent over 145
billion dollars on u.s weapons
on the other hand the russian invasion
of ukraine has given rydia a new
opportunity to gain influence and
recompose its relationship the united
states currently needs oil again and it
needs it this time not so much for
itself but to calm a terribly stressed
market before oil prices begin to
fracture its international alliances
against russia for that and for the 2024
election because you see the evidence
says that every 10 per dollar change in
the price of crude oil results in a 25
to 30 change in the price of a gallon of
gasoline and for every penny increase in
the average us gasoline price more than
one billion a year is lost in additional
consumer discretionary spending in other
words we are talking about tens and tens
of billions that companies could lose
along the way
and going into an election with gas
prices skyrocketing companies losing
tens of billions in business and the
economy reeling in the united states
that is almost a certain death sentence
electoral defeat is a given and we
cannot forget either although its
presence is becoming less and less
relevant the important role that saudi
arabia could play in terms of security
and regional stability this is exactly
why the united states needs to get out
of the middle east and focus on its
major political military and economic
objective asia-pacific region
saudi arabia is a critical partner for
us in dealing with extremism in the
region in dealing with the challenges
posed by iran and i also look forward to
continuing the process of building
relations between israel and its
neighbours anthony j blinken u.s
secretary of state be that as it may a
forthcoming trip by biden to the region
will make it clear whether the
relationship can be rebuilt or whether
it is mortally wounded regia has so far
shown the first signs that it might be
willing to give in
saudi arabia ready to pump more oil if
russian production plunges under ban but
at this point it's over to you do you
think the relationship between saudi
arabia and the u.s can be revived should
the u.s seek to strengthen its old
alliance or conversely should it begin
to regard rydia as unfriendly leave us
your comments below and if you found
this video interesting don't forget to
like and subscribe to visualpolitik if
you haven't already done so also thanks
again to your zap for making this video
possible remember that you can now go to
yourzapp.com politik or use the code
politik and save 60 off the annual plan
all the best and i'll see you next time
[Music]